so I'm going to be talking about
untangling the block dag
so this talk is going to be even though
the workshop is on applications
economics line ethics I'm going to focus
on blockchains and if you squint it
might there might be some things that
look a little bit like economics but for
The Economist's among you it probably
won't look too much like
okay so dag what is a dag and and why do
we want one
oh sorry so first I'm going to explain
what a block dag is and why we would
want to block that and I'll talk a
little bit about the challenges why it's
harder in some sense to block dag
protocol compared to a block chain oh
they'll have a brief and very incomplete
survey of block dag protocols and a
little bit deeper dive into the space
mesh consensus protocol which is a
specific example
so let's start with the ledger this is
basically what all the the blockchain
protocols are trying to build is a
ledger I think what do we actually need
when we create a ledger what are we
trying to do well we're trying to create
consensus on an ordered list so think of
this is the list of transactions and of
course we care about the order in which
I'm jack transactions happen and
concerns us in the sense that everybody
should agree on what's in the list and
what the order is and this is critical
right if you have this it's ledger and
you can think of this as time going by
and the ledger records where the money
is right so the money moves and it's
very important that everybody agree
where the money is otherwise we can't
actually run
but that's not enough right so this
consensus property is something that say
you know Byzantine Agreement protocols
have been doing for a long time but it's
not enough for us to get consensus we
also want this to be irreversible and
what I mean by that is history doesn't
change right so we could theoretically
have a consensus protocol where
everybody agrees at all times on what
the state is but today we agree that
Alice has the money and then tomorrow we
suddenly agree that Bob had the money
all along so that is not a good
situation if we want to run a
cryptocurrency and we'd also like things
like robustness in terms of changing old
history so all of these things are of
course under various assumptions and we
always have to think about now what if
our assumptions are wrong or maybe just
slightly wrong how easy is it to to
break the properties that we want to
achieve and it would be nice if sort of
the older things are the more set in
stone they are because if we somebody
can change something that happened 10
years ago then everything since then is
chaos right but if I can only change
something that happened in the last hour
then maybe I can recover from that so
we'd like things to be sort of more
robust the older they are there are also
some other properties we want like chain
quality this is sort of the distributed
computation thing called liveness but
it's a more quantitative version so it's
not enough that we add honest things
honest transactions we want the honest
transactions to be sort of added in
about the same fraction as they're
actually submitted
again I'm also you know hand-waving a
lot of things here this whole talk is
going to be no not very technical
without any proofs yeah so those are one
of the things that I'm hand waving what
exactly does it mean that there's an
honest transaction here I'm also so here
okay so so actually when what we measure
here is not the transactions but the
blocks and for this talk you can think
of each block as sort of a container for
a transaction we don't really care if
it's one transaction or several
transactions and usually you get a
reward for generating a block but and so
we want the honest parties to get their
fair share of the rewards but I don't
want to go very deeply into this because
only something that we may want and I
think this is sort of the main new thing
that blockchain protocols give us is
this whole thing in a permissionless
setting where basically anyone can join
the system and leave the system at any
time and I don't need to ask for
permission from anyone I just run my own
computer and I can join the system
that's what we want now why is that hard
to get well first of all it's the
adversary right if nobody's attacking us
it would be easy but the problem here is
that the adversary that's attacking us
is very powerful so for example it's not
enough to think that you know people who
are attacking us are going to be
rational they'll only do whatever it is
that gains in the most money at least
maybe some of them are but you know
they're if a protocol is permissionless
enough people can join it there will
always be some people who want to just
you know hack it for fun and they don't
care about making money or on the other
hand if we're talking about and system
with many of these Ledger's then it
might actually even be rational to do an
irrational thing locally in some systems
I mean lose all my money in one system
because I crashed that whole
cryptocurrency
because now I get money in some other
way because maybe I shorted it so we
have to consider a malicious adversary
we also have to consider an ongoing
attack so the adversary is always
attacking we have this these systems are
running all the time there on the
internet and everybody is the constantly
attacked and you know you connect to
computers the internet it starts getting
attacked within about 30 seconds and the
same is a reasonable assumption for a
cryptocurrency systems
and finally think this is what is the
the hardest part is what we can assume
about the network so in most of these
protocols we want to assume that the
adversary has full control over the
network timing why even though the
adversary might not actually have full
control over network timing the network
timing over is sort of bad enough that
you know to be on the safe side this is
something that we should assume now when
I say full control I don't mean
completely full control there otherwise
we just couldn't do anything so the
usual assumption is that the adversary
can delay messages can reorder messages
but it can't stop them forever so
there's some bound say we call it Delta
where say 30 seconds the adversary can
hold a message for 30 seconds but after
that everybody will see it so these are
the sort of the challenging environment
in which we have to work to design the
protocol and we know that consensus is
hard like even if we have fixed parties
we all know who the parties are all
agree on who the parties are and the
network is synchronous right so this is
a classic problem that's been studied
for many many years and the problem is
we don't know who to trust right so we
have we know who the parties are but we
don't know which parties are malicious
and which are not and and this makes it
really really hard in fact it makes it
so hard that permissionless consensus is
provably impossible unless we we do
something else and why is it impossible
because the adversary can create these
civil identities the adversary can
always duplicate itself as many times as
it wants
and now it can have 90% majority of all
the identities and
assuming that you're doing the consensus
based on identity number by then that's
right obviously this morning I presented
a possible obviously permission was
consent this is possible because we'll
get to permission sentence I'm saying
this is like the classic in the classic
model permissionless consent this is
impossible we have to add some kind of
new assumption in order to get
permission with consensus so so we we
need an honest majority but we can't get
that if this is our basic model
well for consensus that satisfies the
standard properties that that's not I
think graph I pass out of paper
you know from us basic assumptions there
are much older papers right like you end
up doing majority base stuff this is
like a classic result from the 70s right
Byzantine agreement requires an honest
majority those were all based on
this is the standard model if you're
changing the model you can do other
things yes and we're going to change the
model so you're right there there are
different ways to sort of define what
you want and then you'll get different
things each person selects you know the
other so okay here this is I didn't
explicitly say but we're talking about
the standard model that's impossible
this is just a bullet point to say we
need to do something different right
every honest party is symmetric with
every other artist party meaning trust
exactly the same group right so yeah but
you also have like Maki and brighter
Byzantine forums you have there were
there there was there's like multiple
papers
but to say that you can't get consensus
with with the without majorities the
slightest imprecise deed let's put all
the statements possibility is true we
all agree yes that's totally correct and
I'm going to show like another model in
which it is possible to get permission
and this is the Satoshi nakamoto's I
think that like the nice observation
that he made where she or they is that
we don't have to look at parties we can
look at resources instead so if we
choose resources that are easy to
measure and hard to fake then we can do
basically switch this on its majority
assumption to an honest majority of
resources and now we can suddenly do
things again no we do need agreement
there's no you don't come oh no
consensus we might not have finality but
we can build the consensus under these
assumptions that does have finality
right not reaching consensus for
realistically you also have been you
having possibilities in the classical
probability and not not a non finality
in classical setting no a synchronous
asynchronous says right my partial
synchrony
that's the negative sacrifice you can
see so it's a different so it depends
exactly how you define it right take it
offline I agree that there are various
differences in the definitions and we're
sliding things under the right gear okay
so how does Nakamoto solution look this
is probably something you all know right
we are going to elect a random leader by
lottery where the probability of winning
depends on the relative resource and now
the leader is going to determine the
next block what is a block again think
of it here is a transaction that also
has a little bit of additional
information in particular it has a
pointer and each block when the leader
generates the block it also decides what
is the correct history so far and it
puts that in the block and because most
of the time the lottery is built that we
have only a single leader elected then
we get consensus right because the
single leader is for a long enough
period for it for more than Delta time
the only one available then everybody
can see that this is the only one and so
everybody agrees and nobody else can try
to present a new leader because they
didn't win the lottery in that time so
we get consensus and that's wonderful
but you know it's probabilistic
sometimes we do have multiple leaders
that are elected at the same time or
nearly the same time and then we have a
kind of race right who gets to win and
the rule for Nakamoto consensus is
basically we wait until the next time
when there's a single leader and they'll
get to choose and in general what we do
is we look at the longest chain so we
take the the chain that has as sort of
the most resources attached to it and
that is the correct chain and all other
blocks are just considered invalid
okay so that was the Nakamoto blockchain
a nutshell and now we can think a bit
about generally what is the the ledger
topology right so now we can think of a
ledger that's built in this way that has
like viscous flavor right then it
composed the blocks that have a
transaction and a pointer now what do we
mean by a pointer a pointer is a hash of
the contents of another block and
because of the way we use these
collision resistant hash functions we
can think of this effectively as just a
unique name for a block there's no like
we cannot find a different name for the
same block so there's only one for each
block and in fact it's a because the
blocks contain the pointers themselves
then a name for a block is also a name
for the entire history that this block
points to so when I point to a block I'm
actually saying this is this block and
what it points to those are the entire
history and the nice thing about this
because I cannot find the different name
for a block and I can't figure out what
the name is before I have the block if I
can point to a block then inherently it
means that I've generated my block after
the block I'm pointing you to was
generated because I simply cannot find
the name of a block or maybe a ancient
say it a different way if I have this
name I can't I can't go backwards and
find a block so the only way I can
generate a valid name is take a block
that I know and hash it so the topology
here implies an ordering relation in
terms of temporal organization I knew
this block and only then I could
generate the block that wants to it okay
so now we're talking about a specific
topology the chain topology where each
block has a single pointer and it points
to some other block
and this has some nice advantages so one
it's very simple everybody understands
what a chain is and two there's a unique
way to order the blocks in a chain that
are consistent with this topological
ordering so basically the topology
completely determines the order of
transactions so all I need to do is say
this is the correct block this is the
end point and now I know everything
about history I don't need anything else
which is really nice and there are some
things that might not be inherent to the
chain topology but they're very nice
properties of this Seneca moto consensus
protocol which are that it also has
these irreversibility and robustness
properties so because when I add a block
I'm basically each block here you can
think of it as contributing a resource
or binding a resource to this pointer
then the more blocks I have so the more
resources support whatever they're
pointing to and so the longer the chain
sort of the more confident I can be that
things that are you know further back in
the chain will not change and this can
be formalized in this sort of
probabilistic way we're saying the the
adversary just the the the probability
that it can ever create a longer chain
basically depends only on this this
length of the chain and a fraction of
the resources of the adversary has so
this is very nice and simple and this is
probably one of the reasons why almost
all of the blockchain protocols are
built in this way
watching that provides that property it
seems like any blockchain would have the
property that if you you know if you
accept a later block your hand accepting
all the earlier blocks so it seems like
confidence and so so that's true but
it's not always true that the resources
are bound in the same way to the
pointers so they don't work in exactly
the same way and you can think of like
different things that you do with blocks
that you know run a separate DFT
protocol and create blocks and it's not
like a one-to-one this resource
bind to the block or even things like
proof of stake where you could create
different blocks using the same resource
and then it's become murkier it might
not cause the the the confidence to grow
and definitely it might not cause it to
grow exponentially say with
it's not clear that this is an inherent
property of a chain okay so that's the
good things about chains I don't how
much time do I have
you've got you've done 14 minutes so 26
so why not just use chains for
everything well specifically this
Nakamoto consensus has inherent
scalability problems and thing is that
here we're really strongly assuming that
there is at some many points in time
only a single block but what happens if
we have many blocks almost all the time
so in this case what we get is a chain
that Forks in Forks and forks and now
the the honest parties when they try to
decide what's the longest chain they
don't agree so the honest parties are
basically splitting their work between
many many chains and the adversary can
then choose which of the chains to put
its own little bit of work on and it can
basically say this chain is going to be
the longest or it can make sure that the
chains all stay about equal so the
forking will continue forever and so we
won't actually get consensus so
basically if Forks are common then we
don't have security and the flipside of
that is if we want security then we need
to make Forks uncommon and for that we
need to have the interval between blocks
between these lottery wins be long
enough that with high probability we'll
get these single blocks but this
interval is a limit right if a limit on
the throughput of the network if we try
to increase the throughput of the
network we have to either put more
blocks per time period or make them
bigger but if we make them bigger it
actually also has a the the the effect
of increasing the network latency this
Delta that we are saying how long that
the messages are delayed so we can't do
that because again we'll get 40 so this
protocol has inherent limits
there are also some problems with the
incentives the the mechanism design here
so I think I showed that there's these
selfish mining problems where actually
if you look at what the rational miner
would do then in some cases it's
actually better to not publish blocks
and let everyone continue and run the
honest protocol it's better to keep it
to yourself and that way you can get a
head start on the next block and make
all the other parties sort of waste
their worth because they're working on
something that won't get chosen and it
turns out if you analyze this it
actually is is a you know the rational
thing to do and if all the honest
parties become irrational instead of
honest if they actually do this then
again security will break down because
if everybody withhold blocks then we
don't get the the next properties that
we want and finally we have this sort of
more general
wasted resources right if we only store
this longest chain then we're losing the
the information that we have in this
whole the whole set of data that we
received so for instance in this graph
right there are many more blocks
pointing to this then pointing to this
so it's in doing that more honest
parties thought that this block was the
correct one than this block if all we
store is the longest path then you know
this path and this path are sort of
equally good and so we've lost this
information so this is sort of that the
motivation we can solve these problems
in different ways and one of the ways we
can solve them is DAGs so the idea of a
block dug is let's allow a more general
topology instead of just having the
single chain will allow graphs that are
not necessarily chains and then we might
have to replace this longest chain rule
with something else of course now we
have a lot more leeway and so there are
actually many very different ways to to
build these DAGs the different kinds of
graphs and also different rules for how
we go from a graph to an actual
ordering of transactions and these
precise choices actually make a huge
difference in exactly what properties we
get from this crook from these protocols
so the advantages are almost always high
throughput because now we can publish
many blocks at the same time and then
depending on how we exactly build these
things we could get lower latency or not
we could get you know a better incentive
structure that does not have these
problems
we could even tour remove the need for
lotteries where you have you know
somebody chosen at random and instead
have you know people being chosen
deterministically every fixed
so there's been a lot of work on dads
this is a very partial list it includes
the things that I know have papers with
something that resembles a proof there
are lots of other things that are sort
of heuristic arguments some of them
might be okay I'm not sure but I think
one of the sort of critical things in
any kind of protocol that you rely on
its security is to give a proof of
security because just running these
protocols won't convince us that they're
secure so I'm going to sort of very
briefly go over these protocols and
apologies to the people in this room who
know much more than me about them and
whenever I make mistakes please point
them out so I'm going to get like give
sort of my view of sort what is the
intuition like the the basic idea behind
these things and and then a little bit
more about space mesh so let's start
with the ghost one of the first one so
there the structure is just like a
slight generalization instead of a chain
we're going to have a tree so we still
have one pointer from each block but now
we keep the whole thing we don't just
keep the longest chain and the main
improvement here is that we're going to
include uncle's so we don't just store
the the longest chain we're also going
to remember that say this block has more
support than this block because this one
has one two three four blocks pointing
to it in aggregate whereas this one has
only three and so even though the
longest chain rule would say no we
should choose this here we're going to
choose this one because it has overall
more support so that's the basic idea it
solves this wasted work problem and so
hopefully makes things a bit harder to
attack it has I think some problems with
the chain quality and like their various
trade offs here but this this thing has
actually been used in practice I think
aetherium is still using a version of it
or not anymore what they never did they
just claimed to use a version of this
okay okay then there are two things that
are actually quite different but I'm you
know globbing them together because they
have in some sense a similar flavor this
is inclusive blockchains and fruit
chains so these are sort of the
structure is now a dag so you can have
actually more than one pointer but it's
sort of a weak dad because actually we
really still care only about the longest
chain so it's specifically in inclusive
block chains what we're going to do is
still choose the heaviest chain for
saying what is the correct history but
now we can also include other
transactions
so if we have transactions here that
don't conflict with those on the main
chain then we can also add them and I'm
going to ignore there there are lots of
especially in fruit chain I think there
are all these mechanisms for how to
design the incentives correctly so how
you you make sure that people are
incentivized miners are incentivized to
create the blocks and to create the
transactions correctly and things like
that and so they solve and many of these
selfish mining problems yes so just a
question I know you're sort of
summarizing a bunch of mechanisms in
general but now there's a bunch of
arrows there blocks that point to
multiple people so some of the
mechanisms have
teacher as well where you don't uniquely
track back that you can like your yes so
so in general we can always say just you
know point to everything you see right
and then after the fact we can say what
would you have done if you had been
saying using the longest chain rule
right and so so like it never hurts us
to include these things I just think
might make a store more stock but here
we're actually using it for a little bit
more than that so we can use similarly
to the Ghost Protocol use it for getting
sort of more confirmations for all their
blocks and also now in addition to what
Ghost does which is just sort of use the
weight of the work to say what is the
correct history here we're also
increasing throughput by taking sort of
transactions it didn't make it into the
main chain okay so that is inclusive
block chains and fruit chain well this
is something I completely ignore it so
they actually have an analysis the the
the incentive mechanism here is
different right you get incentivized not
just for generating a block but also for
generating an uncle and like if you have
a transaction that was included in your
block but wasn't on the main chain or in
fruit chains the the whole wave of
transactions is a bit different so
there's a completely different incentive
mechanism
okay then there's the okie which is a
completely different type of so their
the the structure is actually parallel
chain so they're composing sort of their
regular Nakamoto chains and they have a
fixed number of them sake a chains and
how do they get a full order what they
do is they say let's take some member of
transactions at the end of the chain
which we know we're not convinced of
their validity yet because they haven't
had enough confirmations
so we'll say these are sort of partially
confirmed and now we'll take through the
the minimum where transactions are fully
confirmed they have enough confirmations
on all the chains and then we'll just
order transactions in order of the chain
and of the which chain and then within
each chain and they show a security
reduction to Nakamoto consensus
basically if Nakamoto contends is secure
this should also be
and this mainly solves the throughput
problem so it because it's basically
Nakamoto consensus but in parallel then
you get most of the problems of Nakamoto
consensus except that you now have many
blocks in parallel so you can get more
to a point do they set the hardest
parameter in the same way that Nakamoto
so the hardness is divided so basically
they're setting it so if in a komodo
you'd have one block in ten minutes here
you get one block in each chain every
time so the hardness on each chain is
yeah so I don't see why you could reduce
it to I mean why could there be a fork
on the second chain there can be Forks
but they're solved in the same way so in
each one we take the longest chain yeah
I guess I don't understand how parallel
composition works in in this in the
consensus model because you know as you
said if you just set the hardness of
each of the chains to be one-third
smaller then attacker could still just
attack one of the choking no so the way
you you don't decide which chain you're
going to be mining on but when you mind
sort of the output like when you win the
puzzle it tells you which chain you're
going to be creating your block so so
you can't just say I'm going to mine on
this chain with more power you have to
mind toward simultaneously on all of
them and then you get randomly selected
to be on one of them
that's the trick in the security proof
that you could reduce the hardness it
yes well I actually am not completely
sure what the trick in the security
proof is they didn't go deep into the
details of their proof but but this is
the in the construction that's the trick
okay I mean if Carlos so just to say if
this was correct then parallel
composition basically gets you
everything you wanted right like you
would get you would be able to reduce
the latency because the hardness
parameter is lower and you know I don't
think you can reduce the latency here
because you you have to wait for
confirmation till all the chance Oh
so it doesn't actually help with latency
it helps basically only with throughput
I think and the advantage here is that
it's very simple like you don't have a
complex data structure
then there's that specter again so
Spectre has a full bag where you know
any block can point to sort of
everything it sees and here the idea is
once we have this dag we now need to
decide on the order of transactions or
the order of blocks and the way we do it
is we sort of consider each block as
voting about the pairwise order of all
the previous blocks in the graph so how
do we vote about a pairwise order so
let's think of say this block and see
how it votes about previous blocks so if
we're comparing two blocks that have
chained between them between them then
the order is very clear right so L sees
that J has a path to B so it must be
that B is less than J right because of
this topological property J must have
been created after
okay what about J and F so now there's
no path between them but in this case
actually there's no path at all between
l and m right so L hasn't seen M because
if it had seen F it would have pointed
to F in the dad so if it hasn't seen a
block and it did see a different block
then that block comes first
saw this and it hasn't seen another one
yet so it votes that J is lesson and
then you get the more complex every
situations would have seen two blocks
but there's no path between them and in
this case it uses the recursive
computation and basically says what do
the block the other blocks I see think
about them so here we have one block
that thinks that this block came before
this block right so there's one vote
that this comes before this and no votes
in the other direction so it so L votes
that I comes before J so this is the
basic idea my there's yeah there's more
stuff a simplification of the actual
idea and okay so from this we can
basically get pairwise ordering and
using the more things going on we can
prove that we will actually converge to
so honest parties will agree on the
pairwise ordering but the problem is
they won't agree on the pairwise
ordering of all blocks but they will
only they're only guaranteed to agree on
the pairwise ordering of honestly
generated blocks so the adversary might
be able to generate blocks that sort of
stall where the honest parties are not
guaranteed to ever converge to a common
agreement about you know which one comes
first
and the idea inspector is that if we
think of simple payment transactions
then this situation is actually good
enough basically I don't care about
stalling so
malicious payments honest payments will
always get resolved quickly and no fine
the adversary can wait if it's attacking
things that can slow itself down this
isn't good enough for smart contracts
because there we actually really care
about the entire state and there we need
a full ordering so so Spectre could work
for four simple payment systems but not
for more complex
okay so then the next paper tries to fix
this this is the phantom system again
it's a full dag and here they're going
to get a full ordering on blocks but now
instead of doing this pairwise voting
they're going to do a slightly more
complex thing which is search the graph
for a sub graph that's are very well
connected and the intuition is that if
we think of what the honest parties
generate the sub graph of only the
honestly generated blocks then this
should have the property that it's very
well connected because honest parties
see each other all the time
so if we find such a graph and this
isn't like immediately obvious but this
is something we prove then you know it
will we'll be able to sort of agree that
this is the the right rap and then what
they do this here is the the well
connected sub graph and then the idea
for the full ordering is we'll take all
the blocks in this well connected sub
graph first and put all the blocks
outside of this graph after them and if
we all agree on exactly which blocks are
in the well connected sub graph then
it's also easy to agree on an ordering
because then we can just say order them
by topological ordering and then you
know by ID or something and because the
adversary cannot generate sort of late
blocks that go into this it can't change
history I mean if the adversary tries to
generate a block you know after the fact
and claim somehow that it was earlier
then it won't be in this well connected
graph because the honest parties won't
point to it and so it will always appear
after the the honest blocks in the final
order
okay so in the final few minutes I'll
talk about the space mesh consensus
which is called the tortoise and hare
consensus another kind of dad so one of
the the properties that we worked quite
hard to get here is this robustness to
failures something that actually
Nakamoto consensus has sort of very
easily why do we need to plan for
failures and what do I mean by failure
to I mean failures and our basic
assumptions right so all of the
protocols that I've showed assuming
they're proofs are correct are
guaranteed to get you know all these
good properties if there's an honest
majority or two-thirds on its majority
or whatever they need and the network it
has the you know appropriate
connectivity you know there's a list of
assumptions and you know this is how
proofs work right we have assumptions if
they're all satisfied we get the
guarantees but assumptions in the real
world aren't always satisfied and
especially if we're talking about things
that should be running for a very long
time so even if you have things that are
you know one in you know 1 million or
two to the minus 40 or whatever
sophistical security parameter you like
these are the sort of the things that
people usually choose then over 40 years
or a hundred years these things will
happen and it's important for these
systems to be able to recover
automatically from these assumptions the
reason is the whole point where we're of
using a decentralized permissionless
system is that we don't trust any
central authority and if in order to
recover from a failure we have to trust
the central sort of like somebody has to
say Oh we'll manually switch the code to
do something then we have a problem
so I mean it's not that these things are
insurmountable as we saw you know in the
DAO attack thank you sometimes we can
recover manually but it's much much
better if the system can recover
automatically so what we want is for
these systems to have what we call a
self-healing mode where at least so okay
what can we went
to get after we have this kind of
assumption failure we can't hope that
you know nothing goes wrong and
everything will be exactly as it was
before because otherwise we could just
prove our system is secure without these
assumptions but at the very least we
could hope that we were all going to
agree on the state of the system after
the the good conditions are restored and
ideally we also have this robustness
when I said that older history should be
more secure so we wanted to continue
also in this type of setting so sort of
the assumption failures need to be worse
to change history that's older so
specifically in space smash the cell we
do have the properties but the
self-healing mode actually uses slightly
stricter assumptions so we don't need
complete quiet but we need like the
attack to go down to lower levels than
you know the what we can tolerate when
we're not in self
second thing that we try to achieve with
which space much was to have a race free
protocol basically what we mean is there
are no races and honest behavior is
always rewarded so this is not sort of a
necessary condition for things to be
incentive compatible but if you have
this condition it's much much easier to
formally prove that it actually the
honest thing is the correct thing to do
in particular right the adversary won't
be able to get any advantage by
withholding blocks or you know
interfering in in some other way with
the honest parties because if it could
get some advantage then honest behavior
wouldn't always be rewarded so again our
formal guarantees for this property are
under stricter assumptions so they we
get one third malicious we need a 2/3
honest majority for the sort of standard
guarantees and for this we need I don't
remember but slightly more
the other thing that we can get and this
is something that we required because
our cryptocurrency is not built on
troops of work it's built on proofs of
space-time is that we don't require plus
on lottery so I think all of the proofs
of security of the things I've shown
sort of have this property that blocks
are generated randomly with a Poisson
distribution so they appear with equal
probability in any interval of time and
they use us very strongly to get these
properties that we will converge finally
to agreement and in space mesh we don't
actually need that so we can actually do
it I won't say deterministically because
we do need randomness but we don't need
these these lotteries so we can have
parties generate blocks now every 5
minutes exactly on the hour so how does
it work so here our structure is we call
a mesh layer dag so ideally what you'd
have is blocks in layers so every 5
minutes you have a layer and again this
is not on average every five minutes but
like clock time so 12 o'clock you have a
layer 12:05 1210 and so forth and every
block points to all the blocks it sees
in the preceding layers so actually
formally that it does point to things
that were in earlier layers if if they
haven't been included already but this
is sort of the ideal structure when
there's no attack and in each layer all
the blocks are published at the same
time so layer 1 is published at the same
time there 2 is published at the same
time and now when we want to have full
ordering on blocks we order them first
by layer and then within each layer by
ID again this is the simplification
practice we might do some randomization
within each layer but this is the the
basic idea yeah
I'm trying to understand the proof of
workers or space-time so if I have
multiple identities how does that
reflect in my blocks so so the way you
can think of this is there's a
completely separate proof that I used up
my resource okay I publish it separately
and each of these resource proofs
entitles me to one block at some future
time and that future time will show you
know this block is because of that
resource and when I have published this
proof I might even know ahead of time
exactly when my block is going to be
published yeah so the more the more
resources they have the more blocks I
get how many blocks are per layer so we
basically again it's not a Poisson
lottery but we shuffle the block so that
you have on average the same number of
blocks in each layer so so you have an
expected expected number of those we
have an expected number of blocks per
layer and this is how we limit the it's
not and also you know even if you're
entitled to a block you might not put
your block there so we can't give in
other models of work where you have like
very short time periods you flip a coin
every time to it at the limit you become
not exactly but I mean there is some
randomness there and but it's used in
slightly different ways so okay so now
even though it's I guess morally
equivalent in in say Specter and Fanta
and what we were trying to do is all the
blocks are valid in some sense and we're
just trying to decide on in the ordering
here we have a fixed ordering and we're
trying to decide which blocks are valid
so an adversary can always claim a block
is in layer two even if it now is layer
four and of course we wouldn't want that
to happen because then it would insert a
block into ancient history so we want
blocks that you know are created late to
be considered invalid by all the honest
parties and we want all the honest
blocks to be
considered valid by all on his part so
how do we do it so we also use the kind
of voting mechanism so that here we're
not using this pairwise ordering voting
what we're doing is we're voting on the
validity so each block basically votes
on the validity of all the previous
blocks that it sees so for every block
so say if we look at this block right it
thinks this block is valid and these
blocks are valid this block it thinks
it's invalid because it received it
after the deadline for receiving blocks
from layer two so we we look at this
vote and then how do we vote about
blocks that we haven't personally seen
we count all the votes that we from the
block that we have seen and then we take
the majority
so we're assuming that the majority of
blocks are generating honestly because
this followed from our assumption that
the majority of the resources are
controlled by honest parties and each
resource or entitles you to one block so
this is the equivalent
and now it's fairly easy to see that if
all the honest blocks voted the same way
about sunblock so suppose they all think
that block is honest is valid then from
now on every honest block will always
think that block is honest because
there's always a majority vote for that
block and it just gets better with time
and this argument basically is almost
exactly the same as the argument for why
the Nakamoto consensus get more
confident over time here we get
something you know slightly better
because we have say 200 blocks in each
layer so you get confidence faster right
you have two hundred block majority then
do you have any assumptions on
clock's being somewhat synchronized so
you say something like yes so we assume
that clocks so we sort of hide this in
the network delay so you can assume that
the the clock shift is part of the
network delay but then the delay plus
the clock ship is under say 30 seconds
so this is great if all the sorry this
this we called the tortoise protocol oh
I'll tell you why in a second but this
is great when all the honest parties
agree on sun block but it actually
doesn't work for block that our
adversary generated because Fred were
surly generated blocks it could be that
the adversary delayed them for some
honest parties and did not delay them
for other parties and so some honest
parties think they're on it they're
valid and some think they're invalid and
now the vote can split half half now
with very little power the adversary can
always sort of generate additional votes
that will always maintain this half half
voting split and this is what we call a
balancing attack so this is something
that if we just used this voting
mechanism could go on forever it's the
same problem that Specter had basically
right you would never reach consensus so
how do we solve this we add some
randomness so this is sort of a trick
from standard Byzantine Agreement
protocols right we can't do this
deterministically we're going to add
some random component and the the basic
idea is that we're going to look at the
vote margin so if the vote margin is you
know this block is valid by a huge
majority then it's going to be what
we'll vote that it's valid if it's
invalid by a huge majority we'll vote
that it's invalid but if it's in the
middle we're going to flip a coin of
course if we all flipped separate coins
then this wouldn't help and what we do
is we flip what we call a weak common
coin it's a coin that has a property
that at least with some probability say
I don't know one tenth one third you
know the more the better all the honest
parties will agree what the value of
this coin is and when that happens and
the value of the coins are is that is
the right value then the adversary
didn't guess correctly then we will get
consensus and so basically in each layer
all the blocks are going to vote
according to this coin if there's a
balancing attack until we get a
coin flip and then everything works out
and from then on we just get better and
better confidence using the previous
argument so this is the the sort of in a
nutshell how their consensus algorithm
works what I did not tell you is how we
get this to be efficient because the
protocol I described now is horribly
inefficient and communication and
computational complexity so it's not MP
hard like the Phantom protocol but it is
like n cuter or something worse so we do
have a way to make this better both in
communication and in computation we also
have a way to guarantee that everybody
agrees initially so remember we said
that if everybody starts out agreeing
then we have sort of almost immediate
agreement a confidence but the coin flip
thing doesn't guarantee that that it
takes many layers until I mean maybe not
many but it takes several layers at
least until we agree and what we do is
we add sort of a standard permissionless
a Byzantine agreement protocol where we
run that sort of on the side and use
that to agree on our initial decision
whether a block is valid or invalid and
so we start out in the good case and so
this works as long as their assumptions
hold and only when our assumptions don't
hold then things could get bad but then
we get this convergence from any initial
state so we can go back to the good
state finally there are all sorts of
Ledger's that aren't actual DAGs at all
or or chains to just use a BFT protocols
directly and they get different
properties and I'm completely ignoring
them in this talk but they're out there
and they also have you know some
interesting properties
[Applause]